[Music]
your wounds are barely healed the
heavens
burn this is your fault
[Music]
and you never look below and see what
your kind has walked
i know how he feels but we have the
diamond gates
have stood since the light first broke
over the high
this is diablo long ago my brother
but you don't understand
gaze upon the destruction i have brought
it will be the last thing you see
is scatter destroy the netherlands
i do not fear you neverland
you'll find only death in this eternal
realm
i need fury
machines will devour your souls
more fuel need more time
i'm ready
i will not be denied
need more time
[Music]
the ancient texts describe the terror
demons as
unconquerable foes the dreams of diablo
made flesh
they appear in shadow to torment their
victims
and then in shadow
i will find her and restore hope to the
heavens
keep your guard up there are
in my day but only a scanned few of them
could face the might of an oppressor
this monster towers over the tallest
barbarian
weapons crafted from hell-forged steel
they were last seen with bail during his
resurgence
and left legions of dead men in their
wake
[Music]
ah
uh
you think yourself free from the chains
of fate
nephilim but all will kneel before
diablo
more fury
no way
my armies flow through the hill rifts
heaven will be destroyed long before you
sit
one foot
diablo sought to crush heaven with
despair but i have defeated his champion
and restored hope i believe tyrio's
faith would be restored as well
but he remains lost regardless i will
now shatter diablo's infernal portals
no one has seen an armored destroyer
since diablo was exiled from the burning
hell
centuries
realm should the lord of terror ever
return
[Music]
oh
uh
more fuel
[Music]
um